[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in bill plaschke the
celebrated columnist for the la times
espn around the horn contributor we're
finding freddy freeman is having second
thoughts apparently about uh being a
dodger going back to atlanta and then uh
i guess he's representing himself he's
fired his agents bill joins us now how's
this playing locally bill
this is a great time to be in l.a dan
freddy freeman doesn't want to be here
and russell westbrook does
wonderful wonderful
wonderful vibes wonderful vibes we got
going on here
yeah but you won freddie freeman you
probably don't want it so weird the
friedman thing is so weird
his teammates he's playing tremendously
he's one of their two best players
all-star great hitter but he won't stop
crying his 10 his teammates are getting
a little irritated the whole doctor
organization get a little irritated with
it freddie you know you you you made
your bed you signed for the extra year
out here you made the 25 million dollars
more you know kind of deal with it i
mean it just it's a little unsettling to
see him so upset
about not being with the braves when
he's so embraced in l.a people are
really embracing him but they're
wondering how bad does he want to be
here but of course he's playing well so
nobody's really complaining yet but it's
just it's kind of irritating the whole
way the whole thing is shaking down okay
how what kind of response do you think
he gets tomorrow night at home
i think because his first name is so
easy to chant i think it's still going
to be freddie freddie freddie i think
fans will go even out of their way to
let him know how welcome he is here
and you know maybe they'll get a few
tears out of him for that i don't know
but he had but he has to he's got to
just stop crying he just has to stop
crying i mean i've got nothing against
tears but enough is enough you've moved
on and this could be a concern in the
playoffs i mean how bad is it gonna be
when they play the braves in the
playoffs he's going to be emotionally
invested in that so and also to answer
your poll question it's freddie
freeman's fault he's got the last say i
mean he's he's he's he's controls he
signs the paper he signs the pen you
know he signs the contract he wanted the
extra year he got the extra year he got
the extra 22 million
but also bill i wonder though the
timeline on this that if your agent's
you know playing hardball with the
braves and saying hey i want to deal i
want an answer in an hour from now and
then they decide that they're going to
move on i wonder if freddie thought
hey whatever happens make sure that we
still get the deal that i stay in
atlanta it feels like there's a
disconnect here though between agent and
player yeah i don't know i just still
feel like freddie's a boss i mean the
players are the boss you've had jared
weaver came out here remember years ago
and told scott boris to stick it he was
going to stay in the angels no matter
what
if freddie freddie had to know that he
had he had to have relayed to them
somehow give me the last word he had to
have to be this emotionally invested i
just found it hard to believe that and
then
there's some feeling that what does he
want it both ways maybe he's being so
emotional back in atlanta because he
didn't want to get booed because really
reasonably the player would get booed
right in that situation having played so
many years and they'll walk down on the
team
so it's just the whole thing is weird
and the strikes of dodgers is unsettling
and they just hope it's status quo the
tears dry up and he just keeps playing
are the angels the most
interesting average team in baseball did
you see the mike trout [ __ ] chip video
oh goodness yes he's yes the angels are
on bum they're unbelievable
they're in the shadows out here yet they
have the two greatest players
in arguably in the league and they're
causing the most recklessly and they've
been through i think they're on their
third or fourth manager this year
already with the interims and all the
fighting and everything yes they are and
the sunflower seats was unbelievable it
was an unbelievable throw i mean i just
i i i thought that was that was that was
the throw of the year in southern
california but everything has happened
in the elbow injury yes they're the most
interesting shadow team people in l.a
don't even still don't even notice my
truck was still walking in a coffee shop
and nobody would know where he was up
here is ohtani a big deal
locally
you know
not not really there the angels are
bigger nationally than you are locally
and otani
not really because he doesn't really
connect with a lot of the fan base here
and you know in his his interviews or he
doesn't do a lot of interviews and
he doesn't get around much so no not not
really i mean he's not there's there's
five dodgers that are bigger deals than
him than than ohtani at least five
dollars if not ten dollars bigger deals
no time he's bill plaschke la times
sports columnist contributor to uh
around the horn did you go into the uh
california sports hall of fame
yes i was humbled and honored to be
inducted into this california courseware
it was a cool event it was yeah and
especially all in california but i'm
very
i don't know how they picked me they
must have run out of they they ran out
of athletes it's a big state it's hard
to run out of athletes but they must
have done so i don't know how they i
think alphabetically they just got to
the letter p they got the letter p i
think that that was that that was yeah
that was my thing there were some people
at the bank who didn't even know who i
was
so yeah
the uh headline in your uh column on the
lakers lakers acquiring kyrie irving
would be super weird super dumb
uh felt super desperate too
now that they didn't get him how do you
think uh laker fans should
feel well they should feel
the fact that westbrook is staying we
knew he was staying but the fact that he
just reminded us of this
47 million dollars in singing you can't
break my soul i'm glad we can't break
his soul for 47 million freaking dollars
that that's a that's a comfort
laker fans are they're in trouble
they're they're throwing their hands up
kyrie wasn't going to help he was going
to make it worse
but it's still bad they've got nowhere
to turn i mean their best option right
now is to try to get gary payton but
knowing their luck they'll get the gary
payton senior
again
not the son yeah uh there there is no
this was the final
there needed to be a line in the story
about russell westbrook's degree in the
state for 47 million dollars
thus dashing the lakers playoff hopes
for next season
how much hope is there for the clippers
huge hope i'm on the verge but i'm not
going to do it but i'm going to come
right to the edge of saying or
predicting them to be in the nba finals
next year they're if kawhi learns as
healthy as we think he's going to be
they sign john wall whose body should be
in good shape up ahead and played in 20
months
they got norman powell they assigned
they re-signed roko
they've got a heck of a team they're
they've got to be in my mind considered
one of their favorites in the west next
year if not if not the favor i know
everybody's going to still hop on golden
state
i'm back in the clippers they really
look good
any drama with your football teams
no except for you know sean mcveigh had
the wild wedding video and all that
stuff but no no there's no uh
i guess they're trying to think about
signing obj in the middle of the season
but that's not gonna happen yet no
they're they're deadly they're both
very good and very dull and very uh just
you know there hasn't there's that's
that's the thing the two quarterbacks in
town you think could be la swashbuckling
quarterbacks they're the quietest guys
on the on you know on the planet we
never hear a word from them whatever it
were from any of it like any of either
of the teams so they've been it's almost
like the rams didn't win the super bowl
it's so weird i was talking to one of
their officials it hasn't really sunk in
yet that they're super world champions
and you get swallowed up out here with
all the drama of the lakers and the
drama the dodgers and all that stuff so
maybe when training camp opens it'll be
there'll be some buzz again but there's
no buzz at all right now yeah i wondered
about that that you're right that you
could somehow
get lost as a super bowl winning team
and it's probably only in that market
only in that market with because the nfl
is not the number one sport here it's
not the number just it's the number
three sport i mean it's the number it's
the number one sport but the teams are
ranked probably third and fifth or it's
third and sixth the rams are only third
round lagos and dodgers so yeah i was
talking to one of their officials the
other day and it's like did this really
happen did last january and february
really happened they won a super bowl on
their home field
alcon said all kinds of history and it's
like it never it never existed yeah it's
weird it is and if it was lakers or
dodgers
the party would still be going on it
would be continuing so they still the
rams know they have them you saw the
size of their parade they have a lot of
work to do
and they know it
but they're on the right track but they
have a lot they have some work to do
congrats on the honor bill always a
pleasure talking to you i appreciate it
i'm honored to be on here and uh we'll
see if freddie freeman will uh
dry up
that's bill plaschke la times sports
columnist espn around the horn
contributor and a member of the
california sports hall of fame we